A l’origine d’un mythe se trouve souvent
une prophétie, une parole divine qui guide
le héros dans ses actes.
La prophétie d’Apollon énonce que la ville
qui accueillera Œdipe sera bénie.
Ce vieillard aveugle et déchu, qui attire
les malheurs,
possède le pouvoir d’en prémunir autrui.
A la fin de sa vie, Œdipe, ancien roi de
la cité de Thèbes, est accueilli à Athènes par le roi Thésée,
qui en se montrant charitable
cherche aussi à protéger sa ville et son trône.
Contre l’opinion d’une partie des Athéniens,
Œdipe s’installe avec ses filles Antigone
et Ismène dans le quartier de Colone.
pour se faire accepter, le vieil homme plaide son statut de victime
d’une prophétie qui le dépasse
Cette fin du mythe œdipien, bien moins connue
que les épisodes de l’inceste ou de la
sphinge, révèle une autre dimension du héros.
En rachetant les fautes des Athéniens grâce
à son sacrifice, Œdipe devient une figure
christique avant l’heure.
Et sa mort surnaturelle, dont personne n’est
témoin, ajoute un aspect sacré au récit.
Œdipe Christ archaïque donc.
Pourtant ce n’est pas cette facette du personnage
qui nous reste en mémoire.
Un dénommé Jésus a fait mieux depuis.
Œdipe reste pour nous celui qui, contraint
par la volonté des dieux, tua son père Laïos
pour épouser sa mère Jocaste.
Cette fixation sur un épisode du mythe provient
de l’une de ses réappropriations,
celle qu’en a fait Freud pour la discipline qu’il
fonde, la psychanalyse.
Bien loin de la Grèce, c'est à Vienne en
Autriche en 1900, que Freud repense cette
histoire : il voit dans les atrocités commises
par le jeune roi, la traduction universelle
de l'amour de l'enfant pour l'un de ses parents
et de sa haine pour l'autre.
C’est au prix de cette simplification, de
la réduction du récit à un seul épisode,
qu’il peut être gravé dans nos mémoires.
Freud, en découpant les passages qui l’intéressaient
dans la pièce de Sophocle a du même coup
assuré leur survie dans l’imaginaire collectif.
Ce que subissent les récits mythologiques,
les cités le connaissent aussi.
Balancée entre Thèbes et Athènes, l’histoire
d’Œdipe nous montre le devenir très différent
de ces deux lieux mythiques.
Athènes, acceptant de recevoir le vieil homme
maudit se donne le beau rôle.
Elle restera le lieu de la rédemption, ce
qu’il faut retenir.
Thèbes, qui voit se dérouler sur son sol
les crimes, incestes, parricides, fratricides
et j’en passe, devra sombrer dans l’oubli.
Et la réalité archéologique appuie cette
opposition.
Athènes la merveilleuse, dont les temples
rayonnent à la face du monde, ne pourra jamais
être oubliée.
En figeant une partie de la ville, en idéalisant
sa forme à la manière d’un récit, en
mettant en avant ses plus belles pièces,
elle s’est garantie l’éternité.
Thèbes n’aura pas fait ce choix, ou n’en
aura pas eu l’occasion.
Parlez de Thèbes à un étranger, et vous
n’évoquerez dans le meilleur des cas, pas
plus qu’un bref souvenir de la lecture d’Antigone.
Thèbes a cela de paradoxal qu'elle est l'une
des cités le plus évoquée par la mythologie
et celle étant la plus dépourvue de vestiges
archéologiques.
Sophocle disait qu'elle était « la seule
cité où des mortelles donnent naissance
à des dieux » et pour cause, elle est le
lieu d'origine des plus grands héros de la
mythologie comme Héraclès ou encore Œdipe.
Thèbes la maudite ne conserve presque aucun
vestige de son passé antique.
Ici, pas d’acropole, pas de sanctuaire majestueux,
au mieux quelques traces qu’il faut savoir
lire dans un désordre de fondations et de
structures postérieures.
Au-dessus de la ville antique, des tours médiévales,
des routes, des terrasses.
Une chose est frappante quand on vient à
Thèbes, c’est que cette ville mythique
est comme un mythe elle-même.
Réécrite, transformée, ne laissant apparaître
que quelques morceaux originaux, noyés dans
les réappropriations ultérieures.
Thèbes a changé, et on l’a oubliée, ou
presque.
Pourtant Thèbes est une ville de première
importance dans l’Antiquité.
Par sa position centrale dans la plaine de
Béotie, elle est un point de passage obligé
pour celui qui traverse le pays.
Thèbes, même s’il n’en reste presque
rien possédait des murailles cyclopéennes
protégeant des palais mycéniens.
On essaye d'aller là ?
Ah ? Ouais
Après, si on passe sur les bords du lac on verra s'il y a un beau point de vue
On essaye d'aller par là ?
On sait aussi par les textes que Thèbes était
un haut lieu oraculaire, un lieu où l'on
venait consulter les dieux pour connaître
son destin.
L’épisode de la rencontre entre Œdipe
et la Sphinge devant les murailles de la ville
prend alors tout son sens.
Nimbée de mystère, Thèbes est une cité
où s’entend la parole divine...
Œdipe est prédestiné par les Dieux à tuer
son père et à épouser sa mère.
Effrayés à juste titre par cette prophétie,
ses parents décident de se débarrasser de
ce rejeton maudit en l’offrant aux prédateurs.
Mais Œdipe est recueilli et élevé par des
bergers, il grandit donc dans l’ignorance
de ses origines.
De retour à Thèbes, il triomphe de la Sphinge
qui fait le siège de la cité.
La Sphinge c'est cette créature mélangeant
les traits d’une femme, d’une lionne et
d’un oiseau.
Elle terrorise les habitants de Thèbes et
ferme la cité au reste du monde grâce à
cette énigme : « Quel est l'animal qui marche
sur quatre pattes le matin, deux à midi et trois le soir ? »
Réponse « l'homme, qui
marche à quatre pattes bébé, puis sur deux
adulte et enfin qui s'aide d'une canne lorsqu'il
est vieillard ».
Œdipe, en résolvant l'énigme, libère Thèbes et en devient le souverain,
accomplissant du même coup son destin,
celui du fils de roi de Thèbes, abandonné à la
naissance, et qui prend possession par un
moyen détourné de ce qui aurait dû lui
appartenir de droit.
Son couronnement sonne comme la consolation
de son déracinement.
Mais le revers de ce succès est un parricide,
un inceste, une mutilation et finalement un exil
il tuera son père, couchera avec sa
mère, se crèvera les yeux et s'exilera à Athènes.
Une histoire tragique que les dieux avaient
envisagée, ayant même mis en garde les géniteurs
d'Œdipe, mais comme souvent dans le domaine
du mythe, il n’est pas possible d’échapper
à son destin.
Si cette explication est un terreau très
riche pour la pensée psychanalytique, elle
est pourtant très éloignée de la pensée
grecque du 5ème siècle avant notre ère.
Car Œdipe-Roi, est une œuvre littéraire
appartenant à la culture grecque antique
et dont l'auteur, Sophocle, a lui-même sans
doute retravaillé une légende thébaine
bien plus ancienne et préexistante à la
cité.
« L’Œdipe » qu'un médecin de la fin
du 19ème siècle s'est imaginé, et que l'on
s'imagine encore aujourd'hui, n'est pas celui
des Athéniens du 5ème siècle av. n. è.
Cette histoire, nous la lisons et la répétons
allongés sur un divan tandis que les Grecs anciens
l'écoutaient et la regardaient lors
de représentations théâtrales
le cadre historique, mental et social a changé entre
Sophocle et nous.
Finalement, cette œuvre n'est ni morale,
ni psychologique mais uniquement tragique.
Là où nous voyons un parricide c'est de
la légitime défense dont il s'agit et là
où nous convenons d'un inceste il est surtout
question d'un mariage imposé.
L’image la plus terrifiante du mythe d’Œdipe
roi, n’est pas celle de l’inceste, celle
du meurtre du pèree mais celle d’un homme se
crevant les yeux pour ne pas voir la réalité.
Quand on y pense c’est assez étrange d’ériger
comme figure de proue de tout un pan de la psychanalyse
celle d’un aveugle volontaire.
Bien sûr les mythes ont toujours été des
objets malléables, qui traversent les époques,
c’est leur rôles après tout : ils sont
simplement bons à penser.
Rasée par Alexandre le Grand pour avoir refusé
de se soumettre, la ville de Thèbes a perdu
sa place dans le monde grec.
Cela explique qu’elle ne soit plus sur la
carte du tourisme et du grand public, déchue,
comme Œdipe à la fin de sa vie, n’ayant
pour elle que l’écho d’une lointaine
renommée, ternie depuis longtemps.
Mais si Thèbes est comme les mythes qui s’y sont joués,
alors son histoire n’est pas terminée.
Ce décor n’attend plus qu’une nouvelle
fable
pour lui redonner une place dans notre imaginaire.